تخيل ان الاقتصاد الامريكي اقد انهار
واننا امام ازمه اقتصاديه عالميه ليست فقط
شبيهه بما حدث عام 2008 ستبدو الازمه
الماليه العالميه هذه المره وكانها حفله
شاي وذلك بتوصيف كبير الاقتصاديين في بنك
الاستثمار بانمور جوردن هذا الخيال يمكن
ان يصبح واقعا مع تخلف الولايات المتحده
عن سداد ديونها بحلول الاول من يونيو وقد
تفلس الحكومه في الخامس من يونيو نعم نقصد
هذين التاريخين القادمين بعد ايام
كيف يمكن ان يتسبب اقتصاد دوله واحده في
كساد عالميه تتربع امريكا على راس
الاقتصادات العالميه لكنها ايضا على قائمه
اكثر البلدان مديونيه في العام الاخير
حددت الميزانيه الامريكيه بالسته الاف
وخمسمائه مليار دولار بينما قدرت المداخيل
ب 4600 مليار 1940 مليار دولار هي قيمه
العجز ما يعادل الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لدوله مثل ايطاليا عجزوا الميزانيه
الامريكيه مرض قديم اصاب اقتصادها الا ان
واشنطن وجدت حلا عابرا للازمات بسندات
وزاره الخزانه ظهرت عندما قررت امريكا
دخول الحرب العالميه الاولى وبسبب الحاجه
للاموال باعت الخزانه الامريكيه صكا ماليا
للبنوك مقابل فوائد سنويه لجوء الخزانه
للقروض كان مرهونا بموافقه الكونجرس وتجنب
البيروقراطيه في زمن الحرب الرئيس
الامريكي
اقر عام 1917 حريه الاقتراض لكن بشرط
الالتزام بصف محدد قانون الفائده شرع
ليتغير حصل هذا 100 مره منذ اعتماده
الكونجرس يتدخل في كل مره برفع السقف لكن
الاجراء الروتوني الروتيني يتحول احيانا
الى ساحه لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه على حساب
الاقتصاد كما حدث وقت اوباما
تبدو الازمه الحاليه مشابهه لازمه العام
2011 بين اداره اوباما والجمهوريه ولكن
المره الماضيه كان هناك اطراف اكثر
متدخلين في هذه الازمه ومن بينهم اعضاء
مجلس الشيوخ بالاضافه الى اعضاء مجلس
النواب من الجمهوريين وتسببت الازمه حين
ذاك بانهيار الثقه بسندات الخزينه
الامريكيه وبرفع اسعار الفائده هذه المره
تاخذ وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه اجراءات
سريعه لضمان الثقه واستمرارها ويبدو انها
سوف تدفع اولا المستحقات على سندات
الخزينه وسوف تسير الاسواق كالمعتاد ايضا
المصارف الخاصه سوف تعفي المواطنين من ايه
عقوبات لو لم تصل اليهم معاشاتهم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات